whether that Jacksonville loss would car
I'm not I'm not worried about the
Jacksonville loss the Jacksonville loss
hasn't carried on to the season
whatsoever if you've seen our training
camp or you've seen the way we've played
in the first two games it hasn't had an
impact on our team whatsoever our team
is connected our team has played its
hard out in two games and we've lost two
tough games but there's has nothing to
do with the Jacksonville game and if you
ask anyone in our locker room it has
nothing to do with the Jacksonville game
and that's just the truth it's a
convenient storyline for you and for
everybody else but it's not the truth
we've lost two tough games but the guys
in that locker room the men in that
locker room they are finishers and they
have what it takes and we're excited to
prove ourselves